[Music]
when desert locusts are well-fed they're
solitary creatures but when food becomes
scarce hungry desperate locusts crowd
onto small patches of land where they
can still find something to eat
contact between different locusts 'as
hind-legs sets off a slew of reactions
that change their appearance and
behavior
now instead of shunning their peers they
seek each other out the locusts
eventually start marching and then fly
away in large numbers seeking a better
habitat these gigantic swarms can host
millions of insects and travel thousands
of miles devastating vegetation and
crops they stay close to each other but
not too close or they might get eaten by
their hungry neighbors when many
individual organisms like locust
bacteria and Jovi's or bats come
together and move as one coordinated
entity that's a swarm from a handful of
birds to billions of insects swarms can
be almost any size but what they have in
common is that there's no leader members
of the swarm interact only with their
nearest neighbors or through indirect
queues each individual follows simple
rules travel in the same direction as
those around you stay close and avoid
collisions there are many benefits to
traveling in a group like this small
prey may fool predators by assembling
into a swarm that looks like a much
bigger organism and congregating in a
large group reduces the chance that any
single individual will be captured
moving in the same direction as your
neighbors saves energy by sharing the
effort of fighting wind or water
resistance it may even be easier to find
a mate in a swarm swarming can also
allow groups of animals to accomplish
tasks they couldn't do individually when
hundreds or millions of organisms follow
the same simple rules sophisticated
behavior called
swarm intelligence may arise a single
ant can't do much on its own but an ant
colony can solve complex problems like
building a nest and finding the shortest
path to a food source
but sometimes things can go wrong in a
crowd diseases spread more easily and
some swarming organisms may start eating
each other if food is scarce even some
of the benefits of swarms like more
efficient navigation can have
catastrophic consequences army ants are
one example they lay down chemicals
called pheromones which signal their
neighbors to follow the trail this is
good if the head of the group is
marching towards a food source but
occasionally the ants in the front can
veer off course the whole swarm can get
caught in a loop following the pheromone
trail until they die of exhaustion
humans are notoriously individualistic
though social animals but is there
anything we can learn from collective
swarm based organization when it comes
to technology the answer is definitely
yes
bats can teach drones how to navigate
confined spaces without colliding fish
can help design software for safer
driving and insects our inspiring robot
teams that can assist search and rescue
missions for swarms of humans it's
perhaps more complicated and depends on
the motives and leadership swarm
behavior in human populations can
sometimes manifest as a destructive mob
but collective action can also produce a
crowd-sourced scientific breakthrough
and artistic expression or a peaceful
global revolution did you enjoy this
lesson if so please consider supporting
our nonprofit mission by visiting
patreon.com slash Ted Edie
[Music]